right thanks very much I did take some
great pleasure out to doing that it's
probably a deprived childhood but you
just woke a few people up as well
my name is Andy Crump I will return
tonight supplying a nice committee in
accordance with the normal planning
application rules and I just like to
introduce the top table and banks
committee services Ross chambers legal
services Karen Tate and the team leader
East - my role is an impartial adviser
to the committee I can clarify any
planning issues that arise at such
unbound by the code of Professional
Conduct of the Royal Town Planning
Institute planning committee members are
not bound by the case officers
recommendation or by oral of advice
Thank You Joanna a Dale Barker team
leader thank you everyone
before we start could i just remind
people members public and counselors
like to insure their phones are either
switched off or on silent and please
come we respect the speaker we may not
agree with what I'm saying but please
can you not interrupt right thank you
it's almost like peanuts goal being told
off by the headmaster wasn't it meydani
the first item on the agenda freezer
chairman we have apologies from
councillors brain and st. we also have
apologies from counselor or Donnell the
whom councillor Richards is substituting
and he will be arriving for the start of
the second application can we how many
disguises of interest please okay so
even count
good evening chair and thank you I'm
obviously the ward member of nine chitin
Road so we'll be stepping down from the
committee for that one I'd also like to
declare a non-pecuniary interest with
regard to the trading to nap location I
do happen to know the Sales Director of
Cameron homes but as far as I'm
concerned this is not going to prejudice
any any decision and I'm coming to the
committee this evening with an open mind
thank you just declare an interest in
the item two seven that's the ninth item
road as never the Parish Council I did
express a view on that so I'll step down
from the committee
okay I just like the committee to note
that I've had some correspondence from
Brenda rice and Cumbre parish council
chairman myself and for Grafton and
Robert weeks to do with the applications
number four in number five just question
if you details or I just responded in
and that I would mentioned latter the
meeting thank you
right we've moved swiftly on minutes of
the meetings on the 24th of October the
14th or no them then there's happy that
we can saw on them is a true record
thank you all right thank you I'm now
gonna have to call a slight small
adjournment and we've got a slight
technical hitch that we need to resolve
before we go any further
and it's quite pertinent to the next two
applications and in the meaning spirit
of fairness and equality and fairness
there's something missing that we need
to check out and get to get some
information so unfortunately have to
hello for a slight adjournment
we'll start as soon as possible so thank
you
but we will restart move on to next item
on the agenda which is application
number 18 slash zero White's excite ful
14 calm Brook Road calm brisk
retrospective application for the
retention of gabion wall with Associated
regrading of grain levels behind the
wall the requirements of the existing
drainage ditch along with the northern
boundary of the site with underground
drainage pipes with a small dry stone
wall including brush and debris screen
between the old culvert and the new part
work and the presenting opposite is
Thank You chef the application site is
situated in the heart of convert as
indicated by the black dot the 40 on the
fund number 14 is a grade 2 this is 17th
century stone built cottage located on
Churchill calm Brook the property is
also located within the Compton and
Compton Vernon concert comm Brooke sorry
and Compton Bernie Conservation Area as
well as the Feldon partners special
landscape area the property itself has
been extended to the solid Andrea a
placement outbuilding has also been
erected on the plot the application is
seeking retrospective permission for the
retention of a gabion wall with
Associated reground in of growing levels
behind the wall the replacement of the
existing drain is ditch too long and all
the boundary of sort of underground
drainage pipes where a small dry stone
will including Russian and debris screen
between the old curve a culvert and the
new poly work the end of the rear garden
is adjacent to a water course and
further turn north for the area is a
designated flood zones 2 & 3
however normal works proposed are
located within the zone foot zone area
I've shown on the screen before you is
the old building and the grade 2 listed
building to the left as indicated that
this is a side elevation of the
outbuilding to the east of the principal
elevation this is the garden area
situated to the rear included in the
garden area to that grade 2 listed
building this is a side area the grade 2
listed building as you can see the
extension on the side this is the photo
the Gambian wall the wall is 1.2 meters
high when measured from the ground level
the surplus soil from the Gambian wall
has been used to backfill the ground to
create a flat tourist area of the hole
in the existing area building
approximately 10 meters squared this
photo shows the drainage ditch line to
the east of the outbuilding and this
photo shows a respective works
undertaken on the coal hood
[Applause]
on the update sheet you will notice that
we have recommended a further condition
which is development hereby pre shall be
carried out in accordance with the plans
are submitted and that is all chair
officer recommendation is for approval
dr. Tim good head
thank you dr. Goodhead and thank you for
bearing with us you will have three
minutes would you like to warn and want
a star thanks very much feel free to
start when you're ready and if you could
just press the button hello okay
oh don't get too close okay right i
speakers both the parish councillor and
unaffected resident are most worrying
concern is the infill of the drainage
ditch cannot the first slide please
here we can see the Environment Agency
map showing the surface water flooding
affecting calm Brook our stress surface
water flooding not River flooding the
dark blue line shows an area of high
risk from flooding the area immediately
above the red arrow is the area of
interest you can see that the ditch is
color dark blue meaning it is a high
flood risk area from surface water
flooding and it goes along the whole
length of the boundary not just the
wetland area referred to in the report
so in heavy rain the water course just
above the red arrow feeds the stream
which is the wider blue area to the left
I lift 50 meters downstream shown by the
crosshairs my house sits two meters from
the high risk flood zone hence my
interest 100 meters further downstream
is a road bridge across the stream could
have the second slide please this shows
the floods that occurred in 2007 viewed
from the bridge and I think you could
see that the water flows in this area
can be considerable the ditch which
carries all the water from Churchill
into the stream has now been filled in
and it's been replaced by three small
four-inch diameter pipes which form a
culvert could have the next slide please
here we can see the picture during
construction from the garden of the
neighboring property the neighbors were
concerned about the outflow discharging
towards their land and piling of spoil
against their fence the original ditch
was the width of the whole area between
the gabion wall and the fence was about
two metres wide and was natural
grassland and that soaked up and slowed
down the flow of water from the whole of
Churchill Environment Agency policy
states no water course should be
collated unless there is an overriding
need to do so this policy statement was
on page 1 of the parish councils
representation it was not considered or
referenced in the officer's report the
local of third or flora tea after a site
visit wrote this is not an arrangement
we would have consented the flood
authority is not able to consider
retrospective applications this is not
an arrangement we would have consented
means that if the applicant had made an
application in the proper way before the
work was done the flood or Authority
would have consulted and would not have
consented to it the application the
applicant has identified no good
planning reason for filling in a ditch
that has served as a water course for
several hundred years could have the
next slide please
this slide shows flood water at the
bottom of Churchill immediately outside
the property this was in 2016 at a point
where the applicant complained about
this street you just finish the sentence
up
the applicant is now substituted a wide
ditch all I would say is that the flood
authority have said quite clearly they
would not have consented to this
applicant to this filling in of the
ditch thank you if they have been
assaulted yes brilliant thank you very
much I did give you quite a long
sentence there
okay thank you very much how can you
stay there for questions please any
questions no sir Perry thank you and
good evening
I wonder whether you can advise has the
Parish Council sought any obviously it's
a major concern to you to the Parish
Council and to the village coz the
parish council sought any expertise or
advice from a specialist drainage [ __ ]
consultant at all in respect to this or
flood consultant well the local need
flood or authority we have been in
contact with that they are adamant that
they will make no comment on any works
that have been carried out
retrospectively but you haven't you
haven't gone to a specialist drainage or
flood risk consultant outside the
authority that has commented the parish
as a parish of about 3,000 pounds when
was that was the piping put in before
the heavy rains we had last year and if
so did you have any detrimental effect
from our heavy rains last year in 2016
or 1730 which heavy rains would you be
talking about we had snow no I would say
that this this produces its major effect
on relatively infrequent occasions but
when it does occur as in 1997 2007 it is
very very dramatic indeed another
question is is the ditch spring fed
because I had a problem in the village I
or one of in my ward where the springs
came up and caused flooding is this a
spring fed or is it just a ditch no it's
not
it's not springfed the ditch is dry 90
something percent of the time the ditch
takes all of the surface water from
Churchill from them from the highway
drainage system and puts it into a
culvert and then takes it down to the
stream through this ditch but there is
no there are no Springs above that
you've got three myths already so there
should be three three photographs that
okay okay right I'll work out which
order they're in
and we'll go from there I just want to
show couple of photographs of the
drainage work it's really just to show
what a natural part of the garden they
are and how unobtrusive the are so this
is one of them looking up the garden the
fence is more or less where the boundary
is between the two properties could you
show the other photograph as well there
should be a third when I think from the
no from the from the road is the one
from the road okay go back right okay so
from the road you're looking down at the
drainage works you're looking down
towards the gabion wall that's been
talked about and the alterations to
ground levels personally I can't really
tell what's there there's no impact on
the street scene the conservation area
all the setting of a listed building the
last one which sorry could you go back
to the one showing no that one yes thank
you
the work concerns raised about
overlooking of the neighbor's garden or
the nearest part there is obviously the
applicants land you can see the corner
of the wall
there really is no impact on the
neighbor in terms of amenity when you're
looking across at that garden that's not
an actively used part of the garden I
think I haven't got a huge amount of
comments to make I think one of the
important things to my mind is that a
grant of planning permission tonight
would not prevent the county as the lead
local federal authority taking action if
it was necessary they operate under
different legislation to the planning
legislation they can still take action
in the future if they needed to so a
grant of planning permission tonight
would not affect that I don't think they
will need to take action my client has
taken all the steps that been asked of
him by the County Flood officers and
he's careful to monitor and maintain the
culvert and especially at times of heavy
rainfall he's keeping an eye on how it's
worked and he's taking advice from the
county flood of officers as well I think
the other important point is that these
works have already been considered by
the council in a previous application an
application that was made for these
works on the out building that
application was not refused by the
council on the grounds of there being
any harm from these engineering works it
was refused for reasons related to the
outbuilding so if you were minded to
refuse this application tonight I think
you would need to evidence why there's
been a change in circumstance since that
decision in July 2017 did it lead you to
a different decision tonight we've got
an officer recommendation of support so
I'm not going to say anything more but
obviously I am here to answer questions
and I would like to thank the case
officer David Cutler he has been really
helpful and really professional
throughout this pretty much any
questions
no thank you and we have our warden and
the players catch the mouse
thanks mr. chairman I mean I have to say
this on my report here I think Tim and I
have been looking at the same report so
I'm sorry if I'm repeating what some Tim
has said but I I think I'm okay thank
you thank you good evening committee can
I hopefully you've got the first
photograph there thank you this is a
photograph of the safe garden you are
taking about 30 or 40 years ago on the
lower left side is the small neighboring
Bellevue wall at the front which is
still the same and some of the neighbors
fence pens are still in place - in the
lower Garden the top green arrow on the
left is pointing to the ditch and the
bottom arrow indicates where the large
highways Popol pipe or culvert will be
will discharge service water into the
ditch during heavy rains the plows AIDS
is now coated into 3/4 inch pipes the
applicant statements say that they are 6
in your pipes I can tell you they are
four inch pipes and there's any dispute
about that I'll recommend a site visit
with a ruler we've heard about service
water maps and service water flood risks
from the parish council but the
committee report is silent on that the
risk of service water flooding is a real
and great threat a greater threat than
sea and river flooding so say the
environmental agency it was in the news
as recently as October 2018 you've heard
the environment agency policy that I
quote no water call shall be called
coltd unless there was no overriding
need to do so the Appling says it's it's
for the safety of his grandchildren
credit but this is not a deep gorges is
a minor country ditch dry most of the
time but crucial to both this property
and the neighboring Pakistan Stream
rains the water does flow strongly
during extreme flooding but then it
subsides and the lam recovers very
quickly it just worked perfectly well
for hundreds of years
and why has the applicants constructed
these four foot high a gabion walls they
will be a constant safety issue for
young children
Wilder films you can see from the photo
this garden did not need cherishing to
grow vegetables the report describes the
lapping of the land is that it is some
sort of urban makeover
just imagine him walking down your
gardens find your neighbors ray laced
the whole of this side by four feet
that's four feet higher no I believe the
real reason for this has been done
because self there was a lot of X s
debate his sport get rid of and most of
that came from lowering the level of the
outbuilding without any approval I might
add there is no excuse for this work
hadn't been done without the proper
consent of M permissions in place
I'm surprised as committee report states
at page nine that the federal authority
word can be reinterpreted to mean
something the flood authority had not
said the flood of authority is quite
clear the you saw three small pipes has
reduced the capacity of the ditch and
increase the likelihood of blockages
they have said and I quote again this
news is not an arrangement we would have
consented to they would not consent this
proposal if asked before it was
implemented they do not consent it now
retrospectively it is simple would this
committee have approved this if asked
before it was done probably know what
has changed nothing the committee should
not change its response either I ask
committee please to refuse this proposal
thank you
Thank You committee good evening council
Emile's good evening I wonder whether
you can advise if the flooded the floods
or excess rain of 2007 and 2016 resulted
from waters escaping from this
particular area in the village or did
the flooding was it coming I think I
think sorry I think it contributes to
the whole of the year I mean that was a
as we know it's a bad year that
yeah and this this just didn't help it
it didn't all come from here no didn't
all come from here so there are a lot of
it did because it comes down the hill
from Churchill that's it comes down from
Churchill that's it because that's the
highest point so of course it's going to
hit this point he's weakest point and
then straight through I'd say this is a
retrospective application but had they
put an application in yes I do I vastly
to be refused on this particular reason
it's except forgive my confusion I do
have two questions if I may be the first
one I'm very confused because we've
heard by yourself and parish council
that local elite flood authority have
said that they object to this or would
do a film retrospective
yet in the papers I'm reading that local
leave authority have twice responded and
on both occasions raised no objection
I'm I'm confused
weird confused as well because I say my
my report here where are we going the
flood of authority is quite clear the
use of three small plants have reduced
the capacity of the ditch so that's that
is a problem there so that they've
confirmed that this is this is going to
cause a problem okay
and my second question you may well have
just answered that this is a basically
as three pipes that reply at all but the
replace a dinner that was over for it
goes along the same line presumably the
same amount of water will be traveling
on the same line through the same
culvert oh it's sorry through the same
drainage why is
this gonna increase the level of water
flow through there because of it was a
natural culvert there it is now flat and
the pipes underneath aren't just going
to take it away as I've been a viable
we're also perhaps you've got that
question the first question to to join
the points of clarification a minute
catch the Vance yeah but we this ditch
which continues on after the pipes is it
continuing before the pipes and then no
is it's it's or before the pipes no you
get my straight off the road our seeds I
think you know the question is what can
you explain what's happening with a
local flood authority Authority please
thank answer I stayed in the report the
local lead for the for he has raised no
objection they did stay in there that
although they wasn't have been consented
and his on page 18 of your report the
structure appears who maintained in corn
didn't appraise recommendations how all
we still retain the body under the line
drains act to enforce removal the
structure should it meet in the our
enforcement criteria and then they
further gone to reiterate what they said
in her lay a common and that's the
reason entirely convinced that helps me
if I'm honest on the one hand they're
saying they wouldn't have accepted it if
here's retrospective that was on the
29th 6th of September 18 on the 12th of
October 18 they said no objection but
it's based on the fact that it needs to
be maintained in line with a letter that
the applicant has submitted he's correct
so in yeah you are right if it was right
to spare it's not what they would have
recommended to be done that the works
but when they've gone out and done the
site visit they believe that it's
successful and what is doing in its
capacity and therefore it needs to be
maintained to that level if at any point
comes damaged or doesn't maintain
leveled and under the land Rainey's act
they can enforce it to be removed and
all changed okay sorry if I'm okay to
carry on yeah so again just for clarity
the addition of the conditions in our
update sheet that the development shall
also be carried out in accordance with
the supporting statement I presume that
supporting statement is the maintenance
schedule and by conditioning that we're
making it very clear to the African
that's what we need to do and then
following that the lead floor authority
has the authority to enforce and either
have this removed or improved should
anything get worse technically yes the
supporting statements turning back son
so does the Platinum is reason for did
to be imposed in the update she the land
Rainey's Act is covered under another
plan not a plan to consideration the
yeah that is correct and they can't
enforce it on themselves through that
art and also the supporting statement
and the conditions the plan numbers
gives us the option to make sure that is
maintained as it should work so
essentially we've got two ways in the 14
one is a land drainage act and one is
through our own planning system which is
what he detailed in the update she yeah
very clear thank you very helpful made
it clear - it was pretty no I think I
think between you view taste and very
good anything the as I understand it the
ditch coming to the pipes is open or is
there is there a gully at the beginning
of the ditch to trap leaves and other
debris that could block the pipes and
cancer as you can see on the slide this
before you this is how the ditch
landowners dare to go who's at the
minute in regards to truck and leaves
and is that is the culvert are situated
I'm not an expert on drainage I can't
comment on whether look where it was or
not I'll be honest we're going on the
LFO phase expert voices drying his
engineer
is at the beginning of the Calvados at
the end of the culvert nice the
beginning and ago where so there is no
method to prevent either the pipes being
undermined in excess water or preventing
leaves and other materials that could
block the pipe situate being constructed
to protect or deal with the system I'll
be perfectly honest I'm not a giant good
expert
I could not comment on that okay thank
you
smite sorry before I come in any other
questions so I was missing me laughs
sorry about that um it was rice
borrowing to the speakers that's the
Environment Agency policy that water
courses shouldn't be coveted on this
there are substantial safety reasons and
also regarding the size of the pipes as
well wasn't so the sizes of the pipes
aren't covered in the issues of things
the size of poisoning assessments wasn't
taken boilie I'll FFX
early local authority they're the ones
that were determined that sort of scale
and whether it is accessible or whether
it is right to use them so it's pipes
and as I stated they raises no rejection
for that reason we we find that it is
sufficient in what he's doing I can't
comment personally whether they are
probably stoppers or not ongoing on the
basis of their expertise the drain is
expert thank you no further questions
reports of complications we move on to
the debate to the Perry Thank You chair
I think first of all I would like to say
that I understand the concerns of the
parish council and that and the
neighboring properties because water
damage is
is a terrifying thing to happen and when
we have high waters in that side of
things but then on the other side of the
case where what we have in front of us
is a situation where the local leave
from flood authority visited the site
last month
oh no not last month in October raising
no objection
we've got no objection from the
conservation team which makes it very
difficult from an appeal situation in
finding planning reasons to refuse this
I'm comforted by the fact that SDC are
proposing to put this into a condition
to monitor and maintain the culvert to
the local lead flood authority and
therefore on that basis I'm being pushed
towards the officers recommendation of
grant because of what we have in front
of us
but I would like to say that I do
totally understand the concerns that
have been raised by the villages and the
parish council but on the information
from experts that we have in front of us
as I say I'm I am I'm leaning towards
going with the officers recommendation
sorry before we continue to bake Karen's
got one point of clarification here yes
sheriff I can just clarify that the the
condition doesn't include a maintenance
arrangement for for us to monitor the
culvert the responsibility for for the
culvert lies with the lead local flood
authority in terms of monitoring any any
inputs or any damage to it it's not a
responsibility that falls to the local
planning authority okay so it's just one
catch the bass I think Shane I think
based on the fact that we do have
the local flood authority making no
objection on this on the basis that
there is oversight from them for
maintenance of the culvert and these
pipes
I can't see any planning reason why we
could refuse and actually I think the
officers has laid out his position very
clearly for us to understand the clarity
that we've just been given has helped as
well I've I have a frustration and
irritation with retrospective planning
applications we all know how the
planning law works however it is a
facility available to the public and I
see no reason why we should refuse this
so on that basis I will propose that we
grant in line with the officers
recommendation and including what's on
the update sheet just catch the bounce
yes I'm exactly the same opinion I can't
see a reason for refusal living by the
river I know what the environmental
agencies like one day says yes and one
day says no another day doesn't bother
monkeys unfortunate the build as long as
it's on I know for no ass at all so as
far as I'm concerned there isn't any
block I asked the ward members are a
planning reason that we have in our
court strategy and we don't everyone so
unfortunately I I'm forced to secondly
propose miss fielding I'm not at all
happy that they're not the proper
precautions to prevent a undermining of
the
pipe work and also the preventing of
waste materials going down there 500
there for causing blockages and
therefore flooding in the neighbor's
land
I won't in vote in favor of it thank you
no just my concern is that we haven't
got the evidence or to contradict the
leaf loving and authority so I'm
concerned that the anecdotal evidence
and photographic evidence going back 10
and some cases longer years oh good for
a buck right in the book you know this
is chair of planning committee I would
like to see some more evidence from
independent experts if possible that
contradicts or if you're arguing that
why the evidence put forward by in the
report or on the leaf looking Authority
and without that evidence I think we are
almost hamstrung and what we can do so
that that's just my point or when we
comment any further but we've had a
proposal on a second for that proposal
you happy to accept the conditions
obviously so all those in favor of the
proposal to grant the application five
Chairman against one chan
so that's carried committee resolves to
grant application 1801 86 F you out with
additions in the update sheet thank you
right we'll move on to the next item
which is 1802 374 ful 14 combat comm
Brook retrospective application for the
construction of an outbuilding to
provide additional ancillary living
accommodation and Joe brokers are
presenting office again thank you Joe
thank you the application site is
situated the heart convert as indicated
by a black thought before you number 14
is greater listed the 17th century stone
built cottage located on Churchill comic
the property is also located within the
calm Brook and Compton Burnley
conservation area as well as the failed
and partland special landscape area the
property itself has been extended to the
side and rear a placement our wooden
husband erected on the plot the
application seats retrospective
permission for the construction and an
outbuilding deployed additional axillary
a living accommodation for 14 convert
road and outbuilding was granted
permission on the site following
application reference 1500 for for three
such full with the pros use be in the
garage and workshop the site as
extensive history and relations the
application is specifically detailed in
pages 32 to fade forward committee
purports the building for you on the
plans equates to 5.2 meets two Ridge 2.5
meters to east and four point eight
meters in width as indicated on the plan
before you the height the building has
not changed from that was improved in
2015 however the depth of the building
has increased so it could form eight as
to occur for snorkeling for me as to a
principal elevation facing the road this
is a picture of the outbuilding the
retrospective application that's the
great tool is to build in the extension
this is a site in 2010 or 2009 as before
the building was built this is the
principal evasion of the outbuilding
side elevation of the outbuilding this
is inside the outbuilding and this is
now the studio area a further fate of
the studio area one of the departments
and buildings upstairs in the
outbuilding the top floor of the our
building on the loft space the bottom
floor are the outbuilding on the skin
and this is the bathroom area on the
update sheet before you we were
recommending one further condition
planning permission is forthcoming the
develop metabolic rate shall be carried
out and following plans and drawings are
submitted an officer recommendation is
for approval thank you thank you jack
whoever for speaker which is Brenda
racing from Paris councillor the chair
thank you three minutes as usual would
you like a warning with 30 seconds to go
so I know time
time that's us is really good out there
quite cunning there okay thank you yes
and is that okay
so his decisis sets the context of this
area of the village all of the colored
property that the colored purple color
there is a listed building listed
curtilage this is the the center of the
curtilage area of the village next slide
please
this is the old barn you saw it
previously is your better picture there
actually and there's a garage and
workshop and it was approval for its
demolition and replacements slightly
further into the side garden the village
didn't object to that it's important to
understand that the time the permission
was approved the officer and
conservation officer worked closely with
the applicant and architecture agree
what would be acceptable now you can see
the old barn has a shallow roof it's
also quite low to the eaves at that time
the conservation officer wanted to
constrain the harmful impact of any new
building he did allow it to be a half a
metre wider a little longer probably
even more than half a metre but not much
more and the height between the line to
the eaves and the ridge not from the
ground but the hypes in the line to
these in the ridge a half a meter higher
as well and you can clarify with that by
measuring the approved plans but the
height from the ground to the eaves were
specifically not increased the
conservation officer also required the
doors to be timber boarded closed him be
warded to reflect the original barn and
the use was to remain as a garage and
workshop as was shown on the approved
drawings next slide please
this photo was taken about 130 years ago
and it shows the original barn in a
better condition I didn't have a photo
with the house and together you'll
notice it Nestle's low beside the
cottage
so the approval was for a single-story
timber boarded garage and workshop just
slightly bigger than the existing next
slide please
we're all a bit shocked when this was
uncovered it
instructor from prefabricated panels so
the dimensions would be to a precise
design this wasn't a mistake it was
fixed together on site and kept under
wraps during the process it is nothing
like the single-story garage and we were
expecting it is most definitely a
two-story building and it has never had
a car inside it there our faith carries
doors and they have windows which is
somewhat alien in this central location
this is not what we were expecting it is
basically one of these holiday chalets
we didn't eject storey timber garage we
would never have supported a holiday
shall a like this they have their place
in the right location maybe even in con
work but not in this central location
which is part of our heritage next slide
please
the bottom pitch this is the same
building the bottom picture is the
submitted plan for this building and by
the way the architects draw is called
the eaves lime is lowered on different
drawings that they that they give us
we've asked for this building to be
measured in the presence of our
representative because we don't believe
that picture represents that building
I'm a mathematician and I know about
geometry can I go your final thing very
briefly we believe this report has some
significant errors which are misleading
this committee in relation to the use of
a delegated thank you very much I've got
some questions anyway so can you tell us
about the things you think you're
misleading in the report please yes
there's a delegated report which was
obviously delegated to an officer to
decide and written in 2017 in September
2017 it was a refusal so no one had to
look at it the parish council couldn't
object to us at that time or anything we
saw it when it's been written and if we
had seen it before it been written we
would have still been very pleased
because we liked the refusal however
there were some significant errors in
some of the decisions which were also
part of the lot decisions but comments
and judgments which were part of the
report the report relied upon an
amendment to the original building the
addition of two windows and it became
the approved plan now those of you know
you're planning stuff well we'll know
that an amendment plan does not become
an approved plan the amendment plan
didn't only include two extra new
windows on it included a larger included
a larger building it included
significant changes it included the
ground being lower it was an attempt in
other words to get a permission for what
they had actually built now reference is
made to that approved plan has been what
should be compared with in relation to
what has been done throughout the
delegated report it made no difference
to the grounds for refusal but it's
Sikkim significantly it's affected all
of the other comments about is this
building satisfactory yes we think it's
the right size is this etc etc so
everything was compared with the wrong
plans in the delegated report you heard
the applicants agent mentioned the
delegated report when she talked about
the drainage ditch okay but can we just
stick to this happy counsel Richards I
think I was going to ask a similar
question because you had written to me
it's German and photographed and then
Robert weeks and Carol riches asked me
beat me to it so I was gonna check the
factual validity of the report so
members were aware of what was going on
so we've we've all got the same
information answered you indicate or not
we are all happy and each other
questions right thank you very much that
was really really comprehensive thank
you yep not a problem erasing the
clarifications there was an AMD
submitted in 2015 unapproved the AMD
although there was different plans
mainly the what should have been
approved in 2015 it only covered the
approvement of the two windows it did
not approve the other plans for the
steeper pitches and they're going into
the ground and so forth it was literally
just the two windows we're happy ok ok
so that's good we have one meeting
please gone Katy Perry sure I'm really
sorry but that screen over there from
where we're sitting the picture of the
current building is kind of squashed and
the aspect is is it is it because of
where we're sitting those two from where
I'm sitting that picture is a lot longer
than that one over there and I'm would
you like to get unhappy for three
screens cancer Perry so chairman I'm
sorry to involve myself in this debate
but I think I might have seen something
that no one else has seen except
possibly councillor Perry mmm the
proportions of the computer on which
these presentations are made computer
monitor and the proportions of the
monitors that you use are different so
what you see on those these monitors is
not the same is what's on our screen and
I have raised this with IT and they say
that there's nothing that they can do
about it but it stretches everything so
things that people look fatter
buildings look fatter I don't know
whether that answers your question
counselor Perry but that is the fact at
Casa Perry can you come back to the
microphone so we can hear you please
more than happy to hear you but we can't
hear you wear that microphone I'm really
sorry but if we are trying to make very
important decisions based on the slides
that we have in front of us I have got a
screen over there which makes the the
current building quite similar to the
plan drawing whereas the screen over
there stretches it lengthways and I'd
like to know which slide is the correct
and the N is proportion that catch the
pie the answer to that is come and look
at the slides front here if if people
want clarification of this I'm more than
happy for catch bars please more than
happy for ketchup Aryan candles want to
come and look it yep no strike wire and
sort or whatever the phrases yeah no not
a problem at all it's the best if we
want to make a decision properly yeah
I never thought would be having musical
chairs tonight but thank you very much
but these we've got to get if people got
concerns sorry yeah again you said if
well as members will have to take on
board and speak to Artie about that
because I think there are yeah well
happy and if people have concerns I'm
glad that race now rather than after
meeting right so we'll know move on to
this please the the I don't apologies
for the die and again you've got three
minutes
thank you I think I'll just start
I think the officer report you have is
very good I think it's very well written
I think it's clear and it's I got its
guidance and the way it gets to a
recommendation for you and though you've
just been looking all those screens but
this building in terms of its height its
size its materials is as already
approved by the council in an
application in 2015 it's the same
building all that's changed is that the
driveway has been dug out 33 centimeters
deeper than was shown in 2015 so the
front elevation in effect looks 33
centimeters taller than as it was
approved so if you like the ground level
up to Eve's height has increased by 33
centimeters that the height of that part
building but the overall height of the
roof is not taller than it was approved
so it's the building is no wider it's
the same materials it's the same
building there was a change in ground
levels at the front there was a
retrospective application made in 2017
that sought approval for this this
building
the only reason of refusal related to
the use of the building and the
council's concerned that it might be
used in the future as an independent
dwelling so there were no concerns
raised last time it was refused about
the size the scale the materials the
design it was to do with the potential
use
the building so the officers have
explained in their report and in their
presentation that that one reason for
refusal has been satisfactory addressed
there are conditions proposed to secure
the ongoing use of the building is a
you-sun ciliary to the main house it's
also worth noting in the report that the
officers accept the building has never
been used as ancillary living
accommodation there's no concern or
suggestion that it has been used or is
currently being used as an independent
dwelling this is purely to ensure that
as he goes on it stays on Seri that's
that's a standard condition that you
would see nothing has changed since this
the application was submitted in July
2017 so the only Planning master before
you tonight is the use of the building
there's an officer recommendation for
ground and we simply ask that the
application is now approved do you know
any questions for the agent catch the
barns and carriages
yeah this there was two additional
windows which the officer told you about
which went in the side elevation which
was an ohmmeter amendment I think there
may have been some very minor changes to
the design of the garage doors
I mean it's minor stuff it's not
changing the dimensions of the building
just the 33 centimeters you've talked
about being dug out was that why
submission of an amendment was put in
2018 he's 18 and zero one five zero
three I guess I was before I was
involved but I presume that was
submitted to try and resolve it in that
way and and it was decided that wasn't
possible yeah that was withdrawn so this
ultimately is allowing the Orcas with
almost revisiting that yeah I mean
normally if any of us choose to alter
our driveway that doesn't need planning
permission I think it's because of this
knock on with the building that it's
become a planning application so there
is a planning application to make sure
this building it has consent in the way
that shows now that's where depends on
the engineering works and level of it so
okay so the for the height of the
building you're saying that if there was
a 33 centimeter reduction in the ground
levels but the height of the building is
still the same although in our report
I'm sure I've read that actually the
height
building is 33 centimeters higher than
it was before the overall height of the
building hasn't changed at the height of
the pitch is exactly the same and that's
to what well when you look at it next to
the main house for example you can run
lines across and see it's as per the
approval before so you can run a line
across from the the bridge of the the
out building to the main building and
that hasn't changed but in effect when
you look at the front of the building
I suppose it is 33 centimeters higher to
the eave simply because the grounds been
doing absolutely the the building is 33
centimeters higher but it's been dug in
on the back on the sides these
measurements are still the same it's
only the front where the ground was
where the ground have resulted that's
different
call yep thank you did you indicate good
all right thank you thank you catch the
mils
Thank You councillor Mills good evening
gang committee the application from the
start is a little confusing ass
application published on the 30th of
November clearly says retrospective
application for the construction of an
ancillary domestic building but in the
report is say that the applicant seats
reps effective Brits effective
permission for the construction of an
outbuilding to prove to provide an
additional and ciliary living
accommodation 214 con Brooke however
this application in my opinion must be
the ultimate I had to express the
ultimate in retrospective planning
application by stealth' first light
please as you can see by the report the
first application was for a garage and
workshop the plans even show a car
parked in the garage there was never the
garage it was never a garage next slide
please
but still we had further plans Cherie
car in the garage at the end of 2016
however what we had before us tonight is
a residential dwelling with fake garage
doors next slide please
why fate go at garage doors well they
were forget for war were for negotiating
for a garage in a pre-application just
discussion but they've built something
completely different from the very start
you may be in a bit facetious here but
you could call it the a square
decent-sized garage they'd put a house
on the scheme but just leave the paint
doyle's doors to remind people what it
is how can we be thinking about proving
a building with fake garage doors in one
of our conservation villages and special
link escape areas now how does this
building enhance that count a character
of the area in a significant heritage
area in calm Brook you have all read the
report and hopefully you have will have
visited the site I'm sure you would have
seen the name on the front of the
building as the workshop which it
clearly isn't a workshop as you can see
by the report there been lots of
previous planning application each
trying towards the approved plan to
match what we've actually built until
finally add me
in 2017 it was never built as a
single-story garage and workshop and
eventually ending up with this
retrospective application first
two-story home it is now a living living
accommodation the proposed plan does not
show a kitchen which actually you saw
the photographs it but this applications
plans change from month to month who had
noticed the report on page 32 and
paragraph three the original proved
dimensions in April 2015 were eleven
point two meters long by four point
meters four point eight meters wide and
the heights the ridge at the front
facing the street was four point eight
meters the report does not actually
provide the dimension of this
retrospective building the parish
council request to have it measured have
not been answered and in the report is
it's the conservation officer telling us
he knows it is no point three meters
higher than approved and I believe is
said in October that he has one meter
higher and originally said in July 2017
the increased height and the massing was
not acceptable and which of those
statements do we believe and during all
this chopping and changing with his site
we have completely lost the landscaping
plans residents have contacted me to say
they are very campari they vacant had
fake garage doors what might happen in
the garden at the front inside at some
stage I believe there was meant to be an
agreed landscaping plan for the site
with trees on the side land and provost
scheme agreed on the frontage or they
seem to have got lost in my view this
proposal needs to have a clear and
accurate dimension stated a clear and
agreed landscaping scheme the
conservation and encase officers need to
explain why they now think the height
and massing is acceptable and how they
think the faint dies doors reflect the
original barn that was demolished how
the whole thing in ances the carriage of
the area committee I'm mostly trying to
urge you to reject this building thank
you
against the many Christians it is not
we're starting the changing or the
prospective change in height which I
shall ask our officers to confirm I'm
not right in thinking there's no reason
why everyone couldn't apply to change
the use of their garage into ancillary
combination to their house anyway I also
drank the beginning it was going to be
applied to be a garage where nobody was
opposed to and granted a garage but it
would never you know right from the
start it was never look intended to be a
garage or workshop so the question is no
thank you cancel nails you're free to go
but don't leave the building
we need you thank you very much
catch the Richards I assume we're into
education I want to get in early could
you please bring up the photos of that
you had of the interior of the house for
me or the dwell is very that ancillary
building I should have said
which photo cancer who where your mouse
is now that one yeah that one
what does that represent that was the
original kitchen unit that was refused
in 2017 what has happened as part of
this application is major appliances
that is the kitchen fridge freezers
washing machine so forth Cougars and
that lot have been removed the case
officer I was confident that therefore
the building now is considered unsealer
II to the main honks this is one of the
reasons of the condition and for the
plan numbers and so forth it can only be
used now by living standards as on the
main house and that's why he's
considered unsealer II the reasons for
the refuge on 2017 was there was all the
appliance in here and therefore it could
have been an independent dweller
so you're telling me that the the only
things left in there is a sink and maybe
a kepler a toaster that cook has gone
the dishwashers gone that's gone I'm
assuming that's a fridge freezer yeah my
concern is if we remind you to grant
condition to no kitchen facilities or
appliances should be installed there in
breach of that immediately so are we
gonna enforce and make sure that's
ripped out there's been a debate on what
is regarded as appliances appliances is
meant to be sort of void goods really to
the likes of a toaster and the kettle or
not a lot aren't covered under the
appliances aspect it is more in relation
to the lights or the fridges and a lot
and so forth so what if someone putting
a plug in hob or a plug in an extra
plate can be removed yeah because you
can't I needs to be on ciliary to a
trial it can't be used as a dwelling
house at any point is it considered that
he's going to be an independent living
accommodation then enforcement action
would be taken okay fine so the height
issue can you confirm that the rear of
the of that I'm sorry bowling is as was
approved
originally I can confirm that the case
officers they it was as recently and
that the height is only increased nor
point three meters or at to the front of
the station Thank You chair if we
reminded to grant would it be
appropriate to put or are we able to put
a condition that prevents any holiday
let or letting on the actual building
fathers it has to be used as I'm celery
so the holiday let condition it would be
covered as an ancillary to the main
house he's only use is two ancillary to
the main house so in other only members
of the family living in the main house
can use or guests of the family living
in the main house so it cannot be used
for commercial ultimately as soon as you
see this appear on Airbnb or a another
BMV site enforcement action will be in
theory the whole purpose of the building
is unsere to my house if it's a lettings
accommodation that lot then it is
breaking what the permission is seeking
so just kind of follow up Joe you can
use the guests but not paying guests
you couldn't use it as commercial
activity thank you by the parish council
order a landscape plan more the reason
reasoned if it was approved it's the one
we got there was a 2015 application the
original one there was a condition
imposed on the listed building sent for
landscape scheme that scheme was
approved and the discharge conditions in
2015 not been implemented yet well this
is retrospective of the issues and no
because that is what you see the
Colombian hasn't been retrospective like
the building yeah but the landscape
hasn't been done I thought maybe I
misunderstood but if you go back to the
pictures of the we've got one elevation
here which we can see along a line up
but the other elevation overlooks a
garden those windows are they this seems
to be very much a residential design of
windows and for accommodation is that as
the asian and stated there was
amendments saw so the 2015 amendment for
in additional windows and so forth the
overall design of the building as
premise from the money stayed the same
and it has been altered through the
course but they have all been approved
fenestration details at some point
during the plan in this room right no
move on to the debate so when scandal to
cancer Richards okay so look I've said
already that I find retrospective plan
applications have real irritation and
actually I'm quite keen to find reasons
why one should refuse them purely on the
basis that I don't we have a framework
that we should be sticking to and it
annoys me that people don't that being
said we've really interrogated this
application and I'm struggling to find
any genuine grounds for refusal there is
no reason why an individual can't apply
for a garage and then subsequently apply
to convert that garage into an ancillary
dwelling so on that basis there's no
grounds there the height issue has been
explained very clearly
understandably and actually our
conservation officer has said that lost
0.233 meters a 33 centimeter increase at
the front of the property has occurred
as a result of the this removal of a
reduction in ground level it's not
material enough to refuse so those
really are the two main things that I'm
concerned about the other would be the
you know the potential for it to be
certainly becoming an airbnb or some
other business use commercial use the
case officer has made it very clear that
that can't happen as a result of the
conditions that have been put on so
frustratingly because it's retroactive I
am gonna be going with the officers
recommendation actually I will propose
that we do grant in line with the
officers recommendation and the
additional conditions in the update
sheet that's the bonds yes I think
exactly the same really it's unfortunate
we've had so many applications and so
many changes and so many different
heights and different bits and bits
there and doors so I feel we haven't
really got a reason for refusal I had
other people been in there obviously
enforcement would have have to look at
it but I am concerned that you know
little village like that the landscape
plan has not been started and I would in
the conditions make sure that they are
solid enough and done because although
it does look in keeping it does need
landscaping are you willing to eat
second Hill Thank You chair I basically
have to sadly in in one respect agree
with my colleagues I do find
retrospective planning extremely
irritating we have before us an
application site with a catalogue of
various applications I can't find a
robust plan
reason to refuse what's in front of me
and therefore I have to go with the
officers recommendation Kosovo I
understand the parish councils and the
ward members concern but I have to base
my vote on what I see in what's in front
of me
thank you Scott Conant but I know into
account okay we got a proposal second we
better that all those in fiber to grant
the application you know in this channel
cute committee resolves to grant
applications 1802 three some for if you
are with conditions and also the
conditions in the update sheet
catch the meal somewhat like to join us
there
Thank You counselor Mills that's the
most kind of you to join us
the right we'll move on to our next
application which is 18 / 0 2 5 6 - sash
Fermi London Rhodes Reddington and I
will take a deep breath now a variation
of condition 1 plans of planning
approval 17 / 0 1 line 3 / REM to allow
for minor alterations to elevations of
plots 4 5 10 years and 12 to change the
car ports to carriages the original
application submission to reserved
mutters access appearance landscape
enlightened scale for 29 - Ellen's
pursuant deploying the permission 15/0
183 4 / out on planning permission
pedometers our light into access light
scale the parents and landscape in
reserve for subsequent approval for the
election lot 229 we're all associated
works include an open space resubmission
of application 13 / 0 3 301 / o UT dated
31st of May 2016 in Dallas are presented
officer thank you
I should probably start with two
apologies 1 an apology for making you
say that mouthful when actually this
application is a very very simple
application there's an existing
permission for 29th Wellings this
application is a very to that
application to that permission but
actually what's involved is changes to
five of the garages 5 plots will now
have garage doors if you decide to grant
this application rather than having car
ports that's the total extent of the
change 5 garage doors ii apology is that
I'm not Eddie
I'm afraid I'm substituting for him at
the last minute so the application site
is there before you at the way the black
doctors of the northern
Reddington zooming a little bit closer
there you can see the the site relative
to the adjoining properties and to the
conservation area boundary just to the
south going down to the meat of the
matter it relates to the four plots
there that are highlighted in blue plots
four five ten eleven and twelve and you
can see that the proposal we're putting
in front of you today is shown in those
inserts the garage doors and just by way
of comparison that's what was approved
previously the garages without doors and
that's the only change just to go back
again so you clear garish doors no
garage doors zoom in a little closer you
can see their plot for has two parking
spaces one in the carport and one in
front plot five the same plots ten
eleven and twelve all exactly the same
arrangement one parking space in the in
the carport on one parking space in
front of it each of those car ports is
proposed to be converted to a garage I
think the only other point I'd like to
make chairman is none of the buildings
subject to this planning application
would change in terms of their size or
their openings or the size of their
openings it is only the garage doors
that are changing there are no update
chairman and recommendation is to grant
as shown on your agenda thank you yes
it's part of Constitution and we have
our first speaker was using to start
annoyed
all righty got three minutes
Thank You Geoff Cameron Holmes they're
grateful for the officer recommendation
to permit this application we believe is
is the correct recommendation
however I'd just like to make a few
points in response to the parish
councils concerns which is why this
application was essentially before you
this evening that concerns are
essentially the number of car parking
spaces wouldn't will inevitably be
reduced just during the consideration of
the original reserved matters
application the Highways Authority
commented that garages had to be of a
sufficient size if they would count
towards a parking provision across the
site the minimum internal dimensions for
a single garage or carport was stated as
3 meters wide by 6 metres in length and
a minimum two point four meter opening
this will allows sufficient size for a
medium-sized family car to be parked
inside for the occupants to exit that
vehicle it would also allow a sufficient
space to provide any additional storage
that the residents may require it's
important to note that these internal
dimensions were not dependent on whether
there was a garage door or not in fact
most of the garages on the development
were shown as having a garage door
during the course of the application the
Garrity's were amended to meet these
standards so they could be counted
towards the parking provision across the
site this was accepted by the council
and the application was approved on that
basis as clearly set out in the
application and in the committee report
the application does not see two amended
dimensions of the garages they will stay
exactly the same as previously approved
the only minor change is the addition of
garage doors as per one with the other
carriages on the site given that the
dimensions of the garetty's will not
change from what was previously approved
the parking provision across the site
would not change as a matter of fact
regardless as to whether their garage
doors or not it would there before
therefore will be unreasonable to object
the application on these grounds the
question therefore remains as to whether
the appearance of the garage doors is
acceptable
giving it the same garish doors husband
approved throughout the development
there is no reason why they shouldn't be
acceptable here members in light of this
I respectfully ask that you approve this
mainly amendment to the scheme as Barry
offers officers reckon
datian thank you Thank You mr. white
any questions for the agent now you're
free to go thank you thank you
I need points of clarification today on
difficult to read anything I would say
about that this doesn't stop the warden
member or funny member members upon the
committee actually coming in and looking
at speaking lovers of themselves this
yeah we're here on a regular basis
yeah well we all have problems
councillor Barnes it's the richest all
those in favor
thanks council bonds did you hand up in
favor there did you say did you propose
it
thank you yes I'm just double-checking
because I can't see everybody's hands
come some Mills again please Thank You
committee resolves to grant application
18 / 0 - 5 6 - very
he's got time for any items or any other
business right just allow them to settle
down for two seconds and then when Joe's
ready we'll start with our next
application which is 18 / 0 1 6 0 0 /
ful 9 coins in red was born construction
of one detached bomb grow with all
associated works and thank you the
application so it sits on the inside of
coins room Road within the boat at
barrier boundary of well was born the
site currently has one sucks - Ellen set
within a garden area to the west of the
main dwelling there is also a detached
garage - the water wet East causes or
the dwelling where the pros drown and
we'll we saw it if approved the site as
a parking area set out to the front and
a good-sized rear garden further to the
West beyond the existing garage the
application sorry our - semi-detached
dwellings the ISA site is a detached
dwelling finally to the north of the
island are rare Gardens of the
properties are monitored close bank
foreclose this is an aerial shot of the
site the site is here just there that is
the dwellings two adjacent dwellings
they're nice and small garage boom those
proposed to be sited
please note within this aerial
photograph the very important
architectural styles with on Clayton
Road this is the existing site plan
gary's as indicated on the previous
aerial photo is situated there
number nine a jason prophetess access
coming in two stories one into the East
which is not yet been built where it was
approved in 2016 and the reference 1602
to full one full and that is that is
will be situated just here it's just not
been developed works have not even
commenced the application is seeking
planning permission for the erection of
a Warner bedroom bungalow the existing
garage would be demolished and free
parking spaces will be folded to the
front of the bogie like answer stop ones
aside access would be obtained from the
existing entrance point lead him from
Clinton Road the bungalows proposed to
have two front facing gables are a free
panel window to the west and a single
panel window to the east the existing
goes will be demolished and the bungalow
Prix will be set at five point two
meters in height to the ridge five point
eight meters wide and 13.5 minutes in
length the building line would remain
and set you to the existing building
line as demonstrated on plan before you
the bongos proposed to have two bedrooms
a kitchen bathroom and a rear face in a
living room this is the proposed street
scene if planning permission was
forthcoming as you can see to the right
this is the proved Whelan in 2016 the
photograph before you is the existing
garage this is number nine this is the
street scene along Titan Road to dry and
situate their two stories high the shops
across the road this is the street
singing facing the other way that's why
the one in 2016 would pose this is
Gary's away the bungalow would be
situated if approved this is the rear of
the application site please note the
window there which is what referenced in
the inspectors report and as referenced
in my report in the committee papers and
adjacent to away from door windows
behind this is a street scene favored
facing please note the existing bungalow
which is the same sort of architectural
style style and design situate is there
along the street scene the application
so it would be just there and as
existing number nine this is a panoramic
view of the street singing I will omit
he's done all the scope bit lens so it's
not to scale or completely reflective
fortune I just couldn't do that
there's the bungalow that's where the
house would be situated and that's where
the bond they were proposed would be
built and then was forthcoming and
that's the end of the presentation
a committee site visit was undertaken by
myself comes to the chrome council
failed in cranks of Barnes and the ward
member kind of parry on the fourth of
December they do have good knowledge of
the site and that is all jail officer
recommendations for approval colleges
first speaker please which is kept from
just just ignore cast advance and I
think he was saying that his dog came on
the site visit and I don't intend to
repeat everything that I said last time
I went to to pick really up on two
comments council which is to reiterate
its concern about the parking on the
proposed development there are three
spaces provided in front of the bungalow
one for the proposed development one for
number nine and one visitor space the
submission then states that there are
three further tandem spaces available
this is not however entirely accurate
Planning Commission has already been
granted as you've heard for a two-story
house to be built to the right of number
nine the access for this would remove
those three tandem spaces in effect then
the proposal provides three spaces for a
two-bedroom bungalow and a three-bedroom
house
this is clearly not in accordance with
planning requirements the proposed
parking works only if number nine and
the proposed bungalow are occupied by
the family and planning decisions are
not made on this basis it is not a
planning reason to say that the
bungalows for a family member and
therefore the parking provision is
sufficient the applicant has made it
very clear in the application of this
proposed development is not an ancillary
building to number nine it's an
independent development therefore
planning decisions cannot be based on
the proposed current use and this raises
further concerns about the adequacy of
the parking provision we believe the
parish council that the proposed
development has an impact on the visual
scene on Kyneton Road there's only one
other bungalow on this side of the road
a burglar that we objected to and if the
planning application came and it was
built within the garden of another
property 13 and 13 a however that
development and you saw the photograph
earlier has a significant space between
the two properties and adequate parking
for each along with good amenity space
having said that this development at 13
and 13 a led to an impact on the street
scene and this proposal Farrington
number nine Canton Road would have a
further impact its design does not
reflect the other buildings on the road
and the properties face the road and
there are the semis or detached houses
with a forward-facing aspect this is a
narrow detached bungalow which is at
odds with the properties surrounding it
the applicant makes the assertion that a
building that allows the family to care
for one another outweighs the small
changes regarding the windows of
number-7 day and the impact that he
would have on the street scene however
we would assert that this is not a
planning reason for this development
this is an independent dwelling and the
reasons for approval or rejection should
be based on this the parking provision
which is clearly inadequate for this
site the loss of a minute lead to
certain number seven and the
overdevelopment of the site the impact
on the street scene outweigh the right
to build destroying I would ask that you
refuse it
any questions for the parish council no
be sure
that for us did actually go and visit
the site so we have got a good idea of
the application site done the other
building as well and just racing so we
did spend must have spent half an hour
there so it was it was a good site visit
thank you very much free to go our next
speaker he's lives again with Kay page
who's okey-dokey yeah you've got three
minutes would you like a warning well
yes okay we'll give you 30 seconds good
evening committee our application has
housing my elderly parents at its heart
the last committee meeting raised if we
had consulted the parish council and the
neighbors we did and I subsequently
presented at a council meeting where the
vote was actually a 50-50 split to
support our application the Chairman's
casting vote being against we also met
in a conciliatory manner with the owners
of 7d in the pub as we parted with shook
hands thinking we'd come up with some
areas of potential compromise however
after several further discussions they
decided they would need the birch Norris
end there objection my online research
then showed that their house was already
up for sale and they subsequently sold
and moved out with no further contact
with this application in regarding 7ds
side elevation kitchen window the living
conditions light would be retained the
proposed bungalow roof like the existing
garage pitch roof slopes away from 70
retaining as much exposure to the sky as
there is currently also there is a
benefit of hiding much of the side walls
chimney and drain pipes from the street
view of each of the respective
properties and each other for interest
of comparison 7d next door sits on a
substantially smaller plot than the
space available for the bungalow for a
bungalow the proposed bungalow site
offers approximately 150 meters squared
more than seven day the Kyneton Road
Street View takes its charm and
character from a diversity of styles
sizes and positioning with the proposed
Street View not dissimilar to what
already exists the Street View is not
being compromised
it might be helpful to consider quotes
from the Appeals Appeal inspectors
January 17 report as he recognized that
the plot is entirely capable of
accommodating and sustaining a single
dwelling at that point he'd written he'd
not found undue harm to the character in
the pearance of the area and also
recorded at point 16 I was able to
observe there is a considerable
variation in the space between dwellings
per second within this context the
additional dwelling would achieve
comparable spacing and would not appear
cramped the dwelling would also be set
back from the site frontage so as to
conform to the existing building line
and would achieve a good-sized rear
garden and that was for a two and a half
story building in summary we have
listened and made considered alterations
for this application included shrinking
the bulk of the building to negate
claims of overbearing and overshadowing
effect affecting any area definition of
race and the different the front
elevation of the proposed bungalow
emulates the profile of the existing
garage which whilst mirroring the style
of a bungalow just a few doors away
thank you Jen's these cats were filled
in than cats the bonds
can we go back to the site I'm sorry are
you living in the house at your parents
so if you then build a bungalow which is
so close to the existing house yeah but
the whole purpose of this application is
that we could move my parents in next
door so that we are there at hand to
support them upon just clarifying that
question I'll go a bit further but it's
still an open market property isn't it
that's the bonds yes thank you if you
look at the plan the front is in line
with most of the other buildings now am
i right in saying that the back isn't
because it looks familiar though it's
the extends it's the line that I can see
level with the existing building right
or does he go further
I thought he looks into me so it goes
further into the back garden right the
backs more or less in line with the
existing house at number 9 isn't it if
you I think it goes slightly beyond 7d
living if they're going to be able to
market properties what access is there
to the garden to the bungalow because
the narrowness of one and a half metres
is not going to sort of allow for joint
access between the two properties so
there's going to be a problem in the
future particularly things like
lawnmowers and bins and things like that
I don't think there will be a problem
and it's not a problem for now anyway I
mean that's more of a case of
more of a market commercial problem
later on at the moment there is access
through to the back it does function as
two separate dwellings with two
independent Gardens the the park I
didn't want to point the parking is not
quite as described by the the parish
council there is enough
there's more parking than they said and
the highways have dropped their
objection because we went back to an
earlier layout if they want to separate
them off later and sell them
independently they'll be a resolution to
that job just explain a bit further this
your definition of more parking please
yeah we the first drawing we submitted
didn't have there's an additional
parking space in front of number nine
and we didn't have that we were
proposing parking just down the side of
number nine between number nine and the
dwelling that hasn't yet been built so
the other side from the bungalow I was
objected to the layout we've gone back
to a layout that was that is the same
parking layout as was seen by the
inspector last time around and the
inspector said this is acceptable so
there's basically there's three parking
spaces in front of the new house that
hasn't yet been built for that house
there are three spaces in front of the
bungalow there's a fourth when in front
of number nine and there is space
between number nine and new house for a
fifth space so this five space is
available for the bungalow and the
existing house which is more than
adequate for the draft standards that
haven't yet been adopted I don't think
there is no but any will happen if the
properties are sold
you then have to register the land and
the boundaries with the when once
everything is created and therefore I
would have thought that problems should
be sorted out in advance that's not a
planning issue though I'm afraid that
that just is not yeah I think that's
third point yeah any further questions
planning related to the agent
applicant no thank you ladies you're
free to go all right car warn men please
cancel party
good evening chairman and committee
firstly I'd just like to thank those
councilors who came along to the site
visit the other week your attendance is
much appreciated and hopefully it gave
you a bit of perspective of what we're
talking about this evening secondly I
would just like to reinforce
particularly to members of the committee
who weren't at the previous committee
that I'm not against infill development
on the Kyneton Road in Wales born
providing it is appropriate and blends
in with the character of the neighbor
neighboring properties I actually
supported the application to the right
of the host dwelling which of course
would have , dated a two-bedroom
bungalow far more appropriately and
would have provided a very good
comparison to the sight of 13 a the
picture in front of you shows you the
gap between 7d Kyneton Road the main
dwelling and you can see the the
application site on the left and to the
right is the comparison site that the
applicant is referring to which is a
couple of doors at 13 a kiting roads
that were looking at nine a kind turn
road and 13 a and if you look at the
distance between the neighboring
properties that it's it's not actually
comparable in terms of a plot intrinsic
to my my views are that chiton Road is a
gateway Road into the village with the
application site situated opposite the
library the design of any proposed
dwellings therefore in this central part
of the village are paramount as
maintaining the character of the street
scene and also this particular part of
the village intrinsic to my assistant is
the fact simply the site is too small in
its width to accommodate a single
dwelling and is a significantly smaller
plot size compared to the surrounding
properties in the street scene of a
comparative bungalow such development
therefore result in a cramped built form
and
so currently it fails to comply with
policy cs9 squeezing this application on
to the appeal site dismissed by the
planning inspector means that this is a
clear case of over development and those
proposals would destroy the setting of
properties either side of it in the
center of the village and again is out
of character so in a nutshell this
proposal would also have a negative
impact on the light at the neighboring
property which is to the left of the
application site entering the kitchen
living room by blocking that window the
window faces southeast where the
majority of sunlight enters their main
living space this would affect the
immunity of the occupies occupiers and
course material harm the design of this
bungalow simply does not fit the street
scene it is in a perdu to the plot
having invested in sufficient space
although a bungalow has been built at 13
a kind and road turn to the next slide
please
just two properties up the road you can
see again the size and the space
surrounding 13a this is a significantly
wider much larger prop much larger and
more appropriate size plot go back to
the previous slide please the proposal
is still too close and high in in terms
of 70 and extends beyond the rear of the
property representing two to three times
further back than the existing garage
arrangement members are also reminded of
paragraph 47 of the updated MPP F which
clearly states that planning law
requires that applications for planning
permission be determined in accordance
with the development plan I urge you to
bear in mind policy CS 9 and therefore
for all these reasons refused this
application thank you you mentioned the
previous
and specifically I think he said that it
was refused on the basis of oversight we
have a an extract from that decision
that actually is contradictory to what
you've said where the inspector said the
dwelling would skip over the majority of
it but it's great garden and would not
therefore result in over development in
his eyes he's very clear in that why do
you think this now it does represent an
over development site so what the key
difference is between the size of this
development and what the property goes
beyond that goes further back than the
previous development one of the key
reasons that actually the inspector
refused the last one was the
overshadowing and loss of light into the
property into 7d and that was one of the
key things you do not have the full
report from the appeal in the delegated
report you have some extracts it still
doesn't it still doesn't overcome our
views that it is over development of the
site because it is actually squeezed in
and in fact a similar application in
Mountford closed was actually refused by
this planning application and actually
represented by the agent who was
planning manager for SDC at the time for
exactly the same reason that it was
actually it was a garage looking to be
converted to a two two-bedroom bungalow
and it was received
it was refused to the same reasons
anyway I wouldn't describe you as a pain
I think you're asking challenging
questions well I'm in the good mood in
the spirit of Christmas any further
questions
I've got warden council Perry and
we've seen from you just tell us your
view the agent and the applicant
employed or stated songs which isn't
always carefully stated there was a
potential for five parking spaces my my
views on the parking obviously we
haven't got a an objection from highways
my my concern for the society is the
fact is is the design and development
it's out of character with the rest of
the street scene and is of no comparison
to the looking at those two pictures you
can see it it's easily half the space of
the site that they're trying to compare
it to which is 13 a thank you so first I
have quite a few I think first one is
about this appeal decision clearly we've
got something here that says I've done
the site that sorry that not no donors
right so that can't be the reason that
he's given can you tell me what the
reason was and while you're doing that
can you also tell me the difference in
the size of the property that was
refused then to what the word looking at
now so the main the only reason for
review actually I will try and there was
this window here now what was a proposed
in 2016 was the two-story dwelling which
did extend slightly beyond the garden
there or go back inside in a minute the
inspector found that it would be a loss
of shut in and also it was from a easily
where majority of sunlight would come in
and a massive form he did know however
that there was two doors to rear of the
same property area here which serves the
kitchen/dining unit of the previous
application and that was his only reason
for refusal he did state we
thing that he could accommodate a plot
he noted that there was very in plot
sizes throughout the street and that it
was the only reason for fusion he did
also comment for stated on page 61
report the building did extend to the
backwards beyond the rear of this
property however I will take the extract
the respective orientations such that
your pillows would result in overshot in
part the rear guard on that property the
extent of the harm would not be
sufficient in its own right to have
whole planning permission so the only
real reason was the overlooking to
insult window the reason I've gone to
assessment now is a bungalow in that
area in regards to though I mentioned
the 2016 plot there very representative
and with obviously this is a bungalow
they go the street seeing the two-story
plot was virtually the same width but of
the extending very representative of
this building here situated in that area
okay so so ultimately difference
approach the reason for refusal first it
was overshadowing and overlooking it was
oh no only overlooking because this
overshadowing says on its own it can't
because it was a two-story not a
single-story it's correct the inspector
stated about it would lose all its loss
of sunlight and also it was the mass
form of the two-story building in terms
of its the what's been proposed now
lengthwise that presumably is
significantly longer than what was
proposed then lengthwise no I'll be
honest it's about the same again the
difference being is once again is one it
wasn't sufficient on its own for a
reason for usual and to know it is a
bungalow with a smaller pit with a
pitched roof so on my assessment in my
opinion it wouldn't cause I overshadow
into an extent in the rear garden thank
you and so okay I'm gonna come I want to
compare now 213 a clearly oh it's so
abundantly clear from looking
pictures that the space is bigger is the
the width of the building bigger than
it's been proposed here significantly
bigger not significant bigger so it's
about the same yeah
you're looking very represented in the
same sort of design and architectural
dimensions all good all right thank you
it's the balance you put that plan up
again what I'm trying to ascertain at
the site visit I thought that the new
development was going into the garden
some insistence in the respect of three
or four meters now it looks to me as
though it is shady there isn't how much
further is it against the two adjoining
houses because that was my concern at
the start disease yeah the look on plan
it would be if it was praised obviously
it would line with number nine it would
alignment number nine however it does
extend slightly on an angle from
seven-day you would need to do in a
scale rule to give you exact dimension
so the the other big thing from here I
presume you're referring to our area
this just yeah it's a terrorist area for
the garden that's that's the dimensions
of the building yeah okay just keep on
saying it's it's slightly or a bit or
whatever would you be able to if we gave
you a minister to about to find out how
much it proceeds further back yeah
sorry
I was gonna say two shakes but I think I
think
we're just under a mana break whilst an
adjournment whilst Josiah force
thank you will restart the meeting and
information please yep so the really
property from that point there would be
two meters but however because you can
see there is slight an incline from
there to there is 2.2 meters massive
dimensions of what would extend beyond
70 its Institute and oh man I I just I
just wanted to make sure we're all clear
any other points of clarification can
submit you did indicate sorry that's my
foot sorry I think mine what question is
about the distance between that their
houses so it is that is 2 meters you say
from from that area - there was 2.2
meters what you do have found the site
is about 1.5 meters here you can see
there's not that much at all on the
boundaries but from there is about 1.5
meters within 1 meter from there with
the offense line going down so so it's
so it's 1.5 then goes down to 1 meter
point 5 on the boundary so there to the
door coming out it will be here point 5
minutes from there okay right very much
we go on to the debate now it's a
fielding as Oh voiced I'm concerned
about the distance between the two
properties I fear that in if it is not
or if they if that remains that distance
it is going to cause problems in the
future
it is too tight onto the existing
building and I basically refused it for
those reasons cancel out
suppose that proposal could you just
clarify councillor fielding the basis
for the it is there isn't sufficient
room between the two buildings for
adequate I don't know what I'm allowed
to say future if they were sold off as
properties independently there isn't
sufficient room there for a decent
boundary the 1.5 meters is insufficient
is that yeah yeah something else
yeah thanks which Jim yeah I'm finally
typically it does to me looks like it's
being squeezed in I'm just thinking if
its role reversal if that tiny bungalow
was there originally
then the decided build the house next to
it though stated overbearing wouldn't
they and and there was a shadow on one
of the coat I didn't find that
photograph in case you run the
photographs that a virtual alright no
matter it was does matter it seemed to
be a shadow from I seem to be a shadow
from the existing house on to the
bungalow and I thought well that's gonna
make it difference the tiny it to me is
squeezing it to me it doesn't suit this
street scene I appreciate you've got a
bungalow up the other end but that did
he seem to have a lot more room
I don't quite like you mr. Chairman I I
don't think I'd go with the office
recommendation on this it squeezed in
Joe can you go back to the picture of
the garage front arm please
thanks yeah say this there's a quads
consider here and whilst like there to a
large degree I would agree with my
colleagues that it does feel a little
bit like it's been squeezed in we're
basing that on on what we're looking at
now that in reality the measurement of
the increase in width is two point three
meters and it still leaves 1.5 meters on
either side of that property as access
to the rear of which and that's just to
the other boundaries that doesn't that's
not including further movement across to
the other properties we have an appeal
inspectors of Hill decision that does
say that it wouldn't be over development
at the site to have something there
cited there that as we as we've explored
already that the only reason for refusal
was in fact the shadowing sorry not
shadowing the lost women it about
through overlooking all that must be
taken away by losing a second story this
is a this is a single story bundling so
that in my mind that that concern that
material planning reason has been
removed so then it's the question of
whether the size is appropriate whether
actually it does fit in with the street
scene and as we've seen in thirteen a in
this there's a couple of other examples
along the same street scene of similar
properties being put in was but was this
not ideal not perfect I don't think we
have real planning grounds with which to
refuse this so I won't be absolutely
won't be second in John building casa
fielding stories proposal I will put a
counter proposal in that we do in fact
support the officers recommendation in
line with what's in the report and
salons yes it's you know it's a very big
bungalow it comes to the front goes
further onto the back if it had been a
bit smaller not a problem
the distance between houses is quite
great really compared with Rosa Bosnian
welcome so I don't think there's a
problem in that respect it's just that
my my concern is the size bunk at math
at the back we went to the number 13
that was I supposed to metres less in
length than this one which would have
fitted great so as far as I'm concerned
it's a bit big for the for the site in
this respective book and maths but not
the width right great yeah I'll just you
know come cancer which is yeah I think
this is found the balance I can see best
argument my my concern is still the
overshadowing as far as I'm concerned
some of the others I've been in such a
sort of satisfied with the parking I
think that's been answered as well the
site visit was was very beneficial
so I'll listen to what members have got
to say and just you want to come back in
you've not helped me
so the overshadowing issue whilst I
understand you're saying I think the you
know we are looking at it wasn't every
reason for a fuse on its own it can't be
it's not material enough I don't think
it's very reason for a fuse on its own
inspectors that said exactly that so if
you're going to refuse on the reason of
shadowing then you need to have
something else to support it and I don't
think there is one there's another
reason I would also say that bear in
mind it is a single dwelling single
storey dwelling it's not too dissimilar
to the fight that's already there now so
if there was overshadowing now sorry if
there would be every shadowing there
would be overshadowed in now so I don't
think that it's really a material
consideration there was another one I
think it's just gone a bit further back
it goes back as far as the dwelling in
the middle this is in line what's
current
slightly further away from from the
joining I'm Sam
and I'd also remind members that there
is a there is a need for bungalows
across our district
I'm sure the need is as great in well as
long as it is in other area so just bear
that in mind when you make no decision
right we've we've had two proposals
neither of which have been seconded at
the moment Buffalo was that was it
so we'll take cancer fillings first have
we got somebody who's willing to second
cancer further catch the mouse
we really need to make sure we're
crystal clear and again nothing we'll
need to take some advice from the
planning offices the reasons for refusal
before we go to any vote no no I think
Karen sorry at the planning officers
have to be given the steer of what
you're so you're saying I veto that just
make sure we're clear then
so you're saying over the run through
the site development too cramped yeah
are you any other reason you know we
turn not to lead you get yourself a very
but any other other reasons concern else
can you come in because she wouldn't to
indicate yeah I still don't think it's
in the street scene I never got Bunga
and appreciate what couch officials are
saying about needing more bungalows but
to me it doesn't fit the street scene it
is cramped
he is cramped world-class a castle
Barnes you indicated is law you
mentioned something about crumble 50/50
well mr. chairman really if it was a bit
small of grace far as I'm concerned the
snow is bulk and mass but literally at
the back it is too great but whether
that's the reason for refusal is up to
you number 13 that was a beautiful
bungalow as big but it wasn't as far
back but they are using as much land as
they can and there is a side window for
the kitchen as a whatever you call a
patio at the back which will be
overshadowed as well but you know
I think if we refuse it you know ok
overdevelopment / - cramped and out of
keeping with the streets just to
re-emphasize before the vote that those
they weren't the reasons given by the
appeal inspector when he refused
development on this side the members are
aware of that I want to reiterate that
actually the they not only were they not
reasons used by the inspector they were
reason as an inspector went out of his
way to say were not valid reasons for
refusing just bear that in mind
sure can we just refer you to the street
scene you have in front of you is the
appeal proposal so this is the the
dwelling is just you can see then the
the expanse the width of that that
property and I would refer you to
paragraph 16 of the Appeals decision I
was able to mrs. inspector saying there
is considerable variation in the space
between dwellings along kind - Road
close to the appeal site number 9 a and
number 11 are tightly spaced and there
are other similar examples within the
street scene within this context the
additional dwelling would achieve
comparable spacing and would not appear
cramped in the context of the refusal
reason that you know your your mooting
currently terms of OB development it
does need to be a clear differentiation
between reason for refusal now and the
assessment the inspector made at the
time unless you've got an additional
on the street scene image we got there
what is the difference what is the
distance between the two properties sure
you can see the street scene that and
then I'll show you the stretching of the
proof and see that dimensions
representative yeah you can see that the
dimensions from that bungalow widthwise
to the street scene right I think we'll
that we've had we've had it proposed in
the second I think we'll go to the road
to was to refuse the application
seconded by catch the males so all those
in agreement with that proposal to
refuse to challenge those against one
chairman non abstentions
to chairman committee resolves to refuse
application 18/2 one six zero zero ful
yeah the final reasons who the referral
will come back to me to to sign off
thank you
eat any business right
the meeting is now over thank you and
Merry Christmas